have you come down from the Globes High
yet I have real life is hit the Doom
scrolling is back
uh no I um Life Is Life was good before
the globe and it's even tastier after I
feel very lucky and you're staying
hydrated folks he's saying listen I
don't normally drink water but when I do
it's Fiji
now are we gonna be celebrating tonight
and do you have a speech prepared just
in case uh they only give you like five
seconds so my whole speech is gonna be
I'm gonna thank God thank my family
thank the cast and crew and get the hell
out of there you know I have to know who
designed this jacket the suit goodness
hold this for one second let me
literally look I swear I don't know here
I'll help you out thank you brother uh
my buddy Jack Manson who Styles Jamie
Foxx okay he got he got this going for
me and look it's monogram oh my that's
your name I didn't even see this
hand to God I did not know this was in
the jacket that's your name right there
so that is so funny uh unique threads
there you go unique and custom and
custom Phantom thread stuff exactly
um yeah no I'm gonna whether I win or
not I'm gonna be celebrating tonight
it's amazing while you're also in the
same category as the late great Ray
Liotta how about that
it's an honor it's an honor I grew up
watching him and there are still some
roles of his that I just haven't gotten
around to like I've never seen him in uh
in something wild
like I I can't wait to go back and watch
his work and and keep learning from him
he was a sweet man and a brilliant actor
well I can't wait to keep seeing your
work and you're a brilliant actor so
congratulations yeah bless you you look
awesome I appreciate you too Johnny Cash
opened a restaurant in weho and he's
like yo and was directed by Tim Burton
there we go a little Tim Burton yeah
exactly looking good thank you
foreign